et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
guillaume lacroix bonjour bien vous
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes le
président du parti radical de gauche et
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représenté par fabrice
veysseyre aux dons du groupe ebra les
journaux régionaux de l'est de la france
bonjour fabrice jard ian bourgault la
croix-rouge jour guillaume lacroix on
attend toujours le nom du successeur de
jean castex qui vit ses dernières heures
à matignon et le dit ce matin sa lettre
de démission est prête est ce que pour
vous il faut une femme à matignon pour
remplacer jean cassette il faut de la
compétence et je ne doute pas que les
femmes et de la compétence donc à partir
de là si c'était un être une femme je
pense qu'en politique il faut aussi
éviter toute forme de critères isation
de quotas par principe moi je pense que
ce qui compte pour le pays c'est d'avoir
une première ministre un premier
ministre au service de la france et qui
porte une politique qui soit quand même
celle que les françaises et les français
ont décidé de soutenir c'est à dire une
politique à la fois de raisons mais et
vu la politique de monsieur macron par
des voix de gauche cda par des femmes et
des hommes qui ont décidé qu'il voulait
faire front républicain sans lequel
d'ailleurs le président de la république
n'aurait certainement pas été réélus
aussi facilement voir réélu tout court
donc il faut en premier ministre de
gauche parlant je crois qu'il faut que
la politique qui va être mené entendent
ce qui a été émis comme vote par les
françaises et les français est donc une
première ministre un premier ministre
qui sera nommé c'est le jeu des
institutions et qui doit être à l'écouté
de ce que la france a dit pas aller
coûte d'un projet politique qui n'a pas
reçu le suffrage de la majorité des
français en tant que tel mais catherine
votre
ça ce sera un problème pour vous ce
principe type de profil écoutez le prix
dont la vue d'abord est souverain pour
nommer le premier ministre qu'il va être
amené à le faire moi je refuse de
rentrer dans le jeu de bonneteau dans
lequel on nous un problème si c'est
quelqu'un qui mise en oeuvre après dans
une voûte les gens à la république
considère qu'il faut qu'il nomme un
premier ministre clairement de droite
qui a pris des positions ou une première
ministre qui a pris des positions comme
madame votera contre le mariage pour
tous qui s'est fait partie de ce qu'on
peut appeler la droite réactionnaire
s'il estime que c'est ça le message
qu'il veut envoyer à la france eh bien
il ya des élections législatives les
français lui répondront mais je pense
qu'il faut savoir dire les choses
aujourd'hui le pays est en crise il est
temps schisme il y à des oppositions et
des fractures dans le pays
extraordinaire si c'est ce moment là
alors même qu'il a été élu grâce à la
responsabilité de citoyennes et de
citoyens de gauche que le président de
la république décide de durcir en
mettant quelqu'un qui incarne une droite
réac rire il ya aussi des gens de droite
qui ont voté pour lui sur
28 % au premier tour
beaucoup moins de voix de droite qui
restait au deuxième tour est-ce que les
vous souhaitez que les démons du prg au
gouvernement dans le futur gouvernement
ça n'a aucun sens ce type de réflexion
la façon fonctionne d'ailleurs le
gouvernement par débauchage de telle ou
telle venue de telle ou telle famille
mais je pense que quand vous voulez
faire de la politique il faut de la
clarté faut de la sincérité quand vous
rentrez dans un gouvernement parce qu'on
vous a appelés pour vous même parce que
l'on considère que vous êtes quelqu'un
soit de compétent soit que vous êtes une
prise de guerre symbolique qu'est ce que
vous incarnez à par vous même la
question n'est pas de savoir si vous
emmenez tel ou tel membre d'une famille
politique dans un gouvernement la
question est de savoir quelle politique
vous y mener qu'est-ce arrêtons de
prendre les français pour des imbéciles
la politique n'est pas un cirque ça
n'est pas un spectacle on en voit le
résultat d'ailleurs à force de prendre
les français pour des imbéciles regardez
la manière dont notre démocratie se
radicalise qu'est-ce qui vous oppose
fondamentalement emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui ce qui nous oppose d'abord
c'est la construction sociale parce que
il y a dans ce pays une colère sociale
légitime une colère sociale qui
s'exprime depuis des mois et qui a
évidemment pris un peu plus d'ampleur
pendant la crise du que vides parce
qu'on a vu celles et ceux qui étaient
parmi les plus mal il est entendu que
rien n'est absolument pas entendu quelle
politique sur les salaires a été
réellement aux menées haute une telle
négociation a été rendue obligatoire sur
l'augmentation des salaires aucune
qu'avons nous fait pour mieux considéré
les charges et les conditions de travail
rien cette colère sociale elle n'est pas
venue simplement par hasard elle vient
d'un d'une réalité celle de femmes et
d'hommes qui aujourd'hui sont dans des
situations professionnelles très
compliqué qui ont beaucoup donné qu'ils
ne sont jamais celles et ceux qu'on
reconnaît excès de colère sociale à ne
jamais vouloir l'entendre a toujours la
mettre sous l'étouffoir a toujours
considéré que le seul sujet c'est la
croissance la croissance la croissance
eh bien on finit par oublier que la
croissance ce sont des femmes et des
hommes et quand ces femmes et ces hommes
se rebelle ils viennent à des votes qui
sont des votes de radicalité et donc une
de nos principales divergences elle est
sur la politique sociale ou l'absence de
véritable politique sociale ça veut dire
là on a compris vous êtes contre les
débauchages individuels mais est ce que
vous pourriez travailler un pacs de
gouvernement avec emmanuel macron s'il
prend en compte
sachant que sa première loi il a dit ce
sera une autre voire d'achat je ne pense
pas que ce soit à l'ordre du jour
d'ailleurs j'ai bien noté que le
président de la république avait
diligenté des candidats en marche contre
les candidats prg sortant donc je ne
pense pas que nous soyons partie pour
avoir une discussion d'ordre politique
je pense pas non plus d'ailleurs que
c'était son souhait pas plus que moi je
n'ai jamais évoqué cette hypothèse
politiquement je considère
qu'aujourd'hui l'espace politique dans
ce pays qui manquent et ça fait
longtemps que je le dis c'est un espace
de centre gauche à la fois capable en
entendant les colères sociales à la fois
capable de les traduire en réformes
positives pas simplement une douche qui
crie qui hurlent à la colère sociale
mais une gauche qui transforme la vie
c'est ça qui manque
mélenchon c'est la gauche qui est à son
extrême c'est
la gauche des insoumis c'est à dire une
gauche qui part du principe de faire le
porte-voix des colères suffit non être
le porte-voix des colères est utile
nécessaire pour que ces colères soit
entendu encore faut-il ensuite
transformé ça dans de véritables
réformes qui peuvent changer les choses
et le faire on ait quitté pas le faire
dans une logique qui serait une logique
passéiste d'une gauche qui veut de
l'égalitarisme partout on sait que ça ne
marche pas et pour jean luc mélenchon il
n'est pas capable de transformer cette
colère sociale en réforme y avait une
belle occasion là après cette élection
présidentielle de considérer que jean
luc mélenchon aurait pu lui qui décide
très souvent d'invoquer françois
mitterrand aurait pu considérer qu'il
fallait recréer les conditions d'un
programme commun mais un programme
commun c'est un programme qui allait du
parti communiste au parti radical avec
un vétéran qui s'érigeait au dessus et
en point d'équilibré la celle inverse
qui a été fait ce qui a été décidé c'est
qu' il fallait que chacune et chacun à
gauche aille abjuré trente ans de vie
politique et veulent bien se soumettre à
la plate forme programmatique de la
partie la plus à gauche du spectre et
bien à partir de là oui il y a une
occasion manquée pour la gauche d'avoir
une unité crédible et c'est ce qui amène
mon parti a considéré que dans ces
considérations c'est l'indépendance qui
prévaut est ce que est ce que le
problème pour vous vous connaissez bien
mélenchon dit pas mal d'années vous vous
êtes tenus par les uns donnent pendant
cette période de tractations le problème
c'est mélenchon non mais moi je le dis
j'ai dû à 10 pas les questions je ne
crois pas jean-luc mélenchon est un
homme quelle vraie qualité on le sait
une profondeur intellectuelle qui a une
capacité politique que chacun lui
reconnaît et ça n'est pas le sujet je
crois que il lui a simplement à un
moment où quand vous vous êtes embarqué
avec un entourage de gens qui sont de
plus en plus ultras qui sont dans la
caricature enfin pardon quand on en est
à investir des femmes et des hommes qui
veulent le permis de voter qui veulent
envoyer la police dans les foyers pour
vérifier si les tâches ménagères sont
respectés des femmes et des hommes qui
tiennent des propos outranciers comme
c'était le cas de monsieur boivent
comment voulez-vous ensuite revenir à un
point d'équilibré et de centralité c'est
bien cela qui qui peine aujourd'hui
pourquoi cette union de la gauche allait
factice d'abord parce que par nous
où est la sincérité sa autant de grand
écart idéologique entre ce que certains
raconté il ya quinze jours et ce qu'ils
disent aujourd'hui ça relève plus de la
gymnastique que de la politique mais par
ailleurs parmi comment peut-on défendre
être dans un projet républicain laïc
universaliste et se retrouver à quoi
investir des candidates et des candidats
qui combat de cette vision de la
république comment faire croire qu'on a
été des partis pro-européens et
expliquer demain qu'il faut désobéir
tout le temps enfin globalement il y a
aujourd'hui un marché de dupes sur ce
projet politique les françaises et les
français sont en train de s'en rendre
compte et par ailleurs la sincérité
manque on ne peut pas à ce point en
politique changer d'avis en quinze jours
jean-louis
pourvoi ils ont fait une erreur en
signant cet accord non mais je pense que
les facs oui par principe parce qu' un
accord ça n'est pas allé se ranger sous
une plateforme de quelqu'un un accord
c'est faire en sorte qu'on se retrouve
autour d'une table pour partager mais on
pouvait pas le faire avec autant de mois
de guerre larvée ouverte entre les
partis politiques qui ont d'ailleurs à
gauche conduit à l'élection d' emmanuel
macron parce qu'aujourd'hui on nous
parle de vouloir un troisième tour
contacter ma fac qui a provoqué le
premier et le deuxième tour de cette
manière si ce n'est la division de la
gauche qui a été savamment entretenue
moi j'ai fait partie de ceux qui
jusqu'au bout sont battus pour unir la
gauche du gouvernement oublie assez
reproché on a tout tenté pour essayer de
faire en sorte que la gauche de
gouvernement sudiste et qu'on trouve une
autre solution que de devoir désormais
nous ranger le plus à gauche du spectre
politique est par exemple à la
présidentielle vous avez soutenu
christiane taubira vous ça a été la
première à se ranger derrière jean-luc
mélenchon classique elle ne s'est pas
rangé derrière elle a dit au soir de
enfin juste avant le premier tour elle a
dit que dans ce moment pour faire
entendre la voix de la gauche elle
savoie irait à jean luc mélenchon mais
combien de gens de gauche y compris
modérés ont donné leur voix à jean luc
mélenchon pour qu' il y un porte voix de
la gauche mais ne sont pas forcément
prêts à porter au pouvoir un projet
politique et celui des insoumis il ya
une différence à faire et c'est
différent ça c'est celle qui aujourd'hui
justifier les fractures qui ont dû
encore en ce moment ce que vous
souhaitez aujourd'hui que les insoumis
que cet accord que la nuls soit
majoritaire et que jean luc mélenchon
arrive à métier moi je souhaite que la
gauche qui est capable de gouverner à
yves à matignon je pense que ça n'est
mélenchon ça ne peut pas être sur le
projet des insoumis je pense que il faut
qu'il y ait un projet politique de
gauche qui soit un projet politique
crédible qui rassure il
est d'abord il n'existe pas parce que
vous n'avez pas lu le programme du
berger parce que vous n'avez pas lu les
projets d'un certain nombre de candidats
qui viennent notamment du partizan ont
réuni remet ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui
vous ne souhaitez pas que la nuque est
arrivé au pouvoir elle arrive sur la
plateforme de l'insoumission
mais il ya deux tours à une élection
législative
il y à des candidats au premier tour de
la nuque il ya des candidats de la
gauche qui est une gouge que je
considère en crédibilité pour gouverner
et entre les deux tours et sera
largement temps de voir si les choses
peuvent bouger mais il n'est pas
question dès le premier tour de nous
retrouver à devoir soutenant je le redis
des femmes des hommes qui sont candidats
c'est leur droit le plus strict mafa qui
portent des discours des projets des
valeurs qui combattent à la fois la
construction européenne qui combattent
la république universaliste et laïque
mais enfin ce n'est plus la gauche vous
aviez entamé des discussions avec jean
luc mélenchon même pas nous avons eu des
échanges informels mais jamais de
discussions ouvertes officiellement pour
négocier puisque le
projet politique était clair c'était il
fallait d'abord aller abjuré trente ans
de vie politique et si ni la plateforme
d'e a soumis jeudi juste au passage que
quand on est prêt à abjurer trente ans
de vie politique qui conduit pendant
trente ans on s'est trompé je me demande
si c'est bien utile qu'on continue de se
présenter aux élections on va parler
justement du centre-gauche puisque vous
dis tiens centre gauche qui est à
reconstruire est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
êtes vous parler avec des gens comme
françois hollande quand bernard
cazeneuve qui sont des socialistes qui
refusent cet accord alors j'ai parlé
avec bernard cazeneuve effectivement qui
a quitté le parti socialiste est un acte
politique quand même il a été premier
ministre de ce pays
et il était socialiste il ne l'est plus
souhaitent s'engager dans une
recomposition de magical il fut il ya
très longtemps a dit qu'elle de gauche
mais nous discutons évidemment d'une
recomposition de la gauche et des
échanges et c'est public avec carole
delga aussi à la fois pour des raisons
d'occitanie mais aussi parce que elle
elle est elle aussi mobilisée motivé
pour que les choses évoluent j'ai
discuté avec un certain nombre de
responsables socialistes
moi je crois qu'aujourd'hui on est au
moment d'une recomposition politique
qu'on le veuille ou non que cette
recomposition politique nous amène quand
même à nous interroger sur la façon dont
après la législative nous allons pouvoir
faire évoluer ou pas la gauche et
l'offre de gauche de gouvernement parce
que moi je fais pas partie de ceux qui
veulent était gardien de musée je suis
pas dans la nostalgie d'une boue rouge
d'il ya 5 ans 10 ans des quinze ans
c'est pas mon sujet et j'ai 46 ans j'ai
des enfants de 13 ans j'ai jamais été
ministre un bon sujet à moi c'est pas
d'être le gardien d'un temple c'est de
dire bien sûr qui a besoin d'une gauche
qui se réinvente mais elle ne peut pas
se réinventer en combattant ses
fondamentaux elle ne peut se réinventer
qu'en adaptant ses fondamentaux au
quotidien du 21e siècle qu'est ce que ça
veut dire que vous souhaitez clairement
aux construire un centre gauche avec le
prg et les dissidents entre guillemets
du pen
avec des femmes et des hommes venus du
ps il le souhaite avec des femmes et des
hommes venus de la gauche de la macro ni
aussi et qui quitte en ce moment la
majorité présidentielle et j'en suis le
témoin puisque j'en investi pour les
élections législatives qui souhaitent
être en indépendance et on
des gens qui viennent de l'étendard et
v6 2.8 et moi je considère et qui sont
dans une logique claire l'indépendance
qui sont pas là pour venir élargir la
majorité du président de la république
moi et je pense qu'aujourd'hui il ne
faut plus rien s'interdire
à partir du moment où c'est sur la base
d'un projet cohérent on met clairement
vous souhaitez reconstruire un nouveau
parti avec le parti radical de gauche et
celle du ps qui ne reconnaît ni de chez
emmanuel macron icg avait chanté ça
c'est tout ce jeu numérique ont pris une
partie d'europe écologie les verts qui
ne se reconnaît pas dans la négation des
valeurs européennes une partie de la
gauche républicaine et laïque parce que
sur la laïcité on a un certain nombre de
points de convergence moi je ne suis pas
dans l'enfermement je ne suis pas là
pour créer une chapelle de recyclage
suis là pour considérer qu'aujourd'hui
la mission qui est celle de ma famille
politique historiquement c'est de
défendre la république la construction
européenne et d'avoir toujours été au
centre qui permettait les majorités de
gauche le front populaire quand
j'entends aujourd'hui tout le monde en
parlait en disant on va refaire le front
populaire mais le front populaire
c'est d'abord est majoritairement des
députés radicaux c'est d'abord des
députés centristes et donc bien sûr que
ce gouvernement que ce pays peut être
gouvernée à gauche mais n'est pas
gouvernée par sa gauche il est gouverné
avec un accord entre la gauche la plus
radicale et le centre mais qu'est-ce qui
vous disent
qu'ils sont prêts à reconduire sa santé
je suis pas le porte voix de ni de l'un
ni de l'autre j'ai entendu ballard
cazeneuve diam pardon s'il a quitté le
parti socialiste je crois que c'est pas
simplement par un mouvement de colère
c'est pas son genre par ailleurs donc
c'est plutôt par un un mouvement de
réflexion profonde et je sais qu'il
travaille carole delga a pris des
positions qu'elle a rendu publiques ces
dernières heures moi je considère
qu'aujourd'hui un certain nombre
effectivement de responsables politiques
qui sont en train de mûrir la manière
dont nous allons pouvoir converger les
uns avec les autres pour créer
effectivement une offre politique et
vous irez soutenir les candidats
socialistes
partie d'entre eux demande effectivement
le soutien du prg nous essayons de nous
coordonner ya aucun problème et petit
moment ils auront bien sûr
personne investi 80 candidats prg donc
sur l'ensemble du territoire national
évidemment
s'ajouter un certain nombre de gens que
nous allons soutenir qu'ils ne sont pas
prg mais que nous avons souhaité
socialiste dissident pas seulement il ya
aussi des femmes et des hommes divers
gauche qui n'était pas au parti
socialiste mais qu est-il que c'est pour
eux parce qu'ils ont à l'enracinement
local le moment de se présenter nous
avons apporté un soutien officiel à la
bielle âge dans la circonscription la
15e circonscription de parry bon bref on
sera sur quoi 120 150 et on verra à la
semaine décidé d'enfin la semaine des
candidatures et cette semaine donc on
verra les votre actif être fixée au mois
je pense que ça va être aux alentours de
150 au total on
allait s'annoncer
oui il s'est effectivement ce qui est en
jeu et puis on aura d'ailleurs comme
pertinence de donner corps à cette
recomposition politique est ce que le
parti radical de gauche a encore un
avenir où est ce que vous dites
aujourd'hui les parties je pense que nos
vieux partis ont vécu je l'assumé
totalement on voit bien d'ailleurs enfin
que cette élection présidentielle a bien
montré que que ce soit d'ailleurs les
l'air alors qu'on change et non 14 fois
enfin cdi droite française dans le côté
des partis de gauche on voit bien que
sont le plus vieux parti de fruits alors
c'est peut-être nous et qu'on peut dire
qu'ils sont nos spécificités oui mais
parce qu'en politique on ne meurt jamais
mais enfin on peut on peut lire
lentement
je crois que il ya aujourd'hui un besoin
effectivement d'une nouvelle façon de
faire de la politique mais pourtant je
veux quand même dire deux choses croit
que les partis politiques ont un rôle
essentiel à la fois pour former les
militants parce que on voit bien que
quand on crée que des mouvements dits
populaires on a aussi la difficulté de
se retrouver ensuite avec des femmes des
hommes qui ne sont pas forcément préparé
pas forcément aguerris à affronter le
débat politique qui n'est quand même pas
la moindre des affaires et qu'il faut
pas parce qu'on veut réformer les
parties leur enlever la quintessence de
leur origine c'est quand même la
formation de femmes et d'hommes prêts à
gouverner ou en tout cas à s'engager
guillaume lacroix l'actualité
aujourd'hui c'était à grenoble à un
conseil municipal à grenoble aujourd'hui
avec hull le maire écologiste de la
ville souhaite autoriser le burqini dans
les piscines et considère que c'est un
progrès social qu'en pensez vous si
j'avais la moindre accord sur le progrès
social avec itunes ça se saurait non
mais eric piolle
et malhonnête intellectuellement dans
cette affaire et le sait on ne fait pas
la police des vêtements dans ce pays
c'est une évidence mais on ne promeut
pas non plus tout ce qui peut être
promue en matière de prosélytisme
religieux et on voit bien que en
l'occurrence on est typiquement dans ce
type d'affaires de pure provocation
communication voulue par un certain
nombre de tenants d'une religion qui en
l'occurrence ai dit ça mais tenant
évidemment extrémistes qui souhaite
chaque fois buzz est sûre on nous
empêche on restera nos libertés moi je
n'ai qu'un message dans ce pays à rien
et demander de plus aux musulmans mais
rien n'est demandée de moins ce pays est
une république laïque ce pitch une
république universaliste chacun ses
habits évidemment comme il veut dans la
rue ailleurs dans les piscines ya quand
même quelques enjeux de santé publique
qui doivent rentrer en compte mais
globalement globalement on ne va pas se
faire la courte échelle permanente sur
toutes les provocations qui viennent de
quelques tonnes de quelques tenant
extrémistes vous pensez que c'est une
provocation
eric elle promeut par ailleurs le sein
nu dans la piscine oui mais ça c'est ça
c'est l'hypocrisie du truc c'est je vous
explique que je suis pour le burqini
donc je suis pour les seins nus parce
qu'il a bien compris que recoil quand il
disait je ne suis pas pour leur crise et
celles et ceux qui disaient moi je suis
naturiste est donc toujours avoir digéré
pas me baigner tout effectivement mais
c'est un peu facile parce qu'il sait
bien que le sujet est bien au delà de ça
et d'ailleurs si ça n'était pas le cas
il aurait une magnifique unanimité dans
son conseil municipal à grenoble tout le
monde tout le monde dirait où il n'ya
pas de problème or qu'est ce passe-t-il
aujourd'hui à grenoble toute une part de
sa majorité a fait savoir que jamais à
n'accepterait de modifier le règlement
des piscines donc il peut essayer de
savoir à qui je vois pas le problème
mais là
c'est une atteinte à la conception même
de la république universaliste et
derrière cela c'est aussi qu'on le
veuille ou non un sujet de la façon dont
les religions sont toujours en train de
traiter les femmes d'une manière très
particulière moi je veux bien qu'on
m'explique qu'on n'est pas les femmes en
refusant le burqini mais pardon je
considère qu'on n'est pas les femmes en
leur imposant burqa n'est non plus
rappelons que vous êtes élu 8 cette
région vers noyal dans l'un des plus
précisément le président de la région
auvergne rhône-alpes
laurent wauquiez menace d'arrêter toute
subvention à la ville de grenoble 6
s'est arrêté municipal passé vous serez
derrière wauquiez à ce moment là je suis
rarement des routiers
vsr que moi de provocateurs à
provocateur
j'ai du mal à m'y retrouver c'est comme
un peu cette conception maintenant de la
démocratie qui voudrait que les deux
blocs de radicalité a plus un immense
bloc de la raison une espèce de trou
noir comme on vient d'en observer dans
l'espace qu'elle se noierait tous les
gens de bonne composition mais qu'est ce
que c'est que cette farce est-ce qu'on
est chaque fois obligé dans le débat des
publics démocratique de tomber dans
toutes les provocations alors je
n'accepte pas les provocations d'eric
yole je n'accepte pas plus les
provocations de laurent wauquiez je me
bats pour une république respectueuse
respectueuse de toutes et de tous mais
qui évite de tomber chaque fois qu'elle
le peut dans à peu près tous les sujets
qu'on nous impose malgré nous c'est
olivier les subventions c'est un mauvais
levier et là moi je crois que non mais
c'est pas le sujet des trains bus et le
vie et le sujet c'est de savoir comment
vous l'utilisez la piscine à grenoble
n'y a pas que des gens en burqini et
j'espère qu'il y en aura d'ailleurs pas
mais si vous couper les subventions
voulait couper pas casser destructive
portes le mercredi c'est ton que une
provocation politique bien sûr merci
beaucoup merci guillaume lacroix barrez
fait notre invité ce matin président du
parti radical de gauche et merci à vous
et à vos dons
[Musique]